الحصول على مكان فوق اسطح تلك القطارات
يعد بمثابه الفوز بجائزه عالميه لا يفكرون
في عواقب تلك المخاطره هم يريدون الوصول
الى منازلهم فحسب حتى وان كانت وسيلتهم
قطارات الموت في الهند وبنجلاديش
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
تمتلك الهند ثاني اكبر شبكه سكك حديديه في
العالم يركب حوالي 23 مليون مسافر هذه
القطارات يوميا اي حوالي ثمانيه مليارات
رحله سنويا
تاريخيا يعد السفر بالقطار اكثر امانا من
السفر بالحافلات والسيارات لكن هنا الامر
مختلف تماما فهذه القطارات الريفيه السيئه
السمعه خطر يهدد حياه الكثيرين تدافع
وشجار بشكل يومي للظفر بمساحه صغيره على
اسطحها رغم علمهم بمدى خطوره تلك الرحله
عربات ملئت بالبشر من جميع جوانبها اكوام
بشريه تعلقت على الاسطح والنوافذ والابواب
وكوارث وخسائر بشريه بالجمله
احد اكبر اسباب الوفاه على السكك الحديديه
الهنديه هو خروج القطار عن مساره وسقوط
الاشخاص من قطارات مزدحمه كما ان قرار
الحكومه بدعم اسعار ركوب قطارات السكه
الحديد جعل ايراداتها غير كافيه للانفاق
على تحسين مرافقها
داخل عربات هذه القطارات عالم مختلف تماما
لمن ابتسم له الحظ وتمكن من الدخول فهذا
الرجل استغل الوقت للاستعداد لمقابله اهله
بعد السفر لايام ومنهم من يسوق منتجاته
للركاب من حوله ومنهم من غلبته هموم
الحياه
السكك الحديديه في الهند عدت اكثر الطرق
فتكا في العالم حيث سجلت اكثر من 27 الف
حاله وفاه في عام 2014 اي ما يعادل حوالي
530 حاله وفاه في الاسبوع والامر لا يقل
خطوره والما عما يحدث في بنغلاديش
تلك الدوله التي يتسابق فيها البشر للحصول
على مساحه تعادل كف اليد من اجل التشبث
بالوصول او ربما التشبث بالحياه من جديد
في رحله لا ملامح لها انها مغامره مميته
بلا شك بالرغم من ان حكومه البلاد هناك
حضرت هذه الممارسه مؤخرا
بعد قرار المحكمه العليا في بنغلاديش لا
يمكن للقطارات نقل اي ركاب اضافيين على
السطح من الان فصاعدا وسيتم اتخاذ اجراءات
ضد مسؤولي السكك الحديد في حال انتهاك
القرار
شبكه السكك الحديد في بنجلاديش يبلغ طولها
3600 كيلومتر وهي لا تتسع لحمل المزيد
والمزيد من الركاب ونقلهم خاصه في ايام
الاعياد والمناسبات الحكومه هناك تسجل
باستمرار حالات وفاه لمسافرين بسبب السقوط
او الاصطدام بفروع الاشجار المتدليه او
الجسور المنخفضه لكن وبالرغم من ذلك تتكرر
تلك المشاهد ولا مانع اوراد عليهاؤلاء
المساكين فاغلبهم يلجا لاسطح القطارات
لانه لا يملك المزيد من المال فامتلاك
مساحه سنتيمترات على اسطح هذه العربات
مجاني تماما ولا يدفع لها اي ثمن لكن
الثمن الذي ربما يدفعه احدهم هو حياته فهي
وان كانت وسيله سفر مجانيه الا ان طريقها
محفوف
بخطر الموت في اي لحظه
[موسيقى]